A lot of us start with AI in a pretty
simple way. Either using it day-to-day
or wiring it into an app. You send a
prompt, you get something back, maybe
through chatbt or through an API in your
product. And if you've been doing that
for a bit, then you know the limits. It
holds up until you need the system to do
more than generate text. You need it to
use tools to call APIs or update records
and sometimes run a multi-step workflow
that coordinates several steps. Well,
that's where agents enter the picture.
Hey, I'm Gil with Mastra and I spent
over a decade building and teaching
software and I was early to working with
and teaching things like Rag and MCP
style systems when people first started
asking how this stuff actually works.
And as more people try to build and use
agents, I kept getting the same
questions about fundamentals. And as I
was learning it, I realized there's no
single course or even a complete book
that pulls it all together. I had to
piece it together the hard way. So, I'm
going to make it easier for you. In this
course, we're going to build an AI agent
with MRA, an open- source framework for
building agents in Typescript. We'll
give it tools to call code and workflows
for multi-step tasks and add memory and
storage so it can carry context and tool
results across interactions. Now, before
we dive in, the quickest way to see what
you'll learn is to watch an agent run.
Then, you can decide if this course is
for you. This is an AI agent built with
MRA. It's designed around the patterns
people are using today to build AI
powered apps, from agents and tools to
workflows, memory, and observability all
in one place. It's built to take you
from early prototypes to production
ready apps. And it can run alongside the
TypeScript stack you already use or as a
standalone server. When you create a
master project and run it locally, you
get a development studio out of the box.
This is where you can run and test
everything as you build. Here's the
default weather agent. I'll ask it about
the weather in Miami. Here you can see
the tool call kickoff. The tool returns
data and the agent responds. And that's
right, this week it's a little bit
colder than usual down here. And if you
open the trace from this run, you can
follow it step by step. The tool call,
the arguments is sent, and the result
that came back. Okay, I'll ask a
follow-up question. What should I do
today based on the weather here? And
this time, the agent uses the earlier
context from the run I just did. And
these suggestions look pretty great to
me. From here, you can switch models,
tweak the system prompt, adjust model
settings, and see how the agents
behavior changes.
Now, in code, it's pretty
straightforward. You create an agent,
give it instructions, and register the
tools it's allowed to call. And those
tools, well, they're just TypeScript
functions. Now, some tasks are clearly
defined up front and need to run in a
specific order. That's what workflows
are for. Workflows break work into
explicit steps. You can run them
directly in Monster Studio or have an
agent trigger them. And you can even
pause the workflow at a step for human
approval as you build. Monster Studio's
observability view is where you verify
what actually happened. You can see what
ran, what got called, what the model
saw, and where things might have gone
wrong. You can also add scoring to see
whether the agent's doing what you
expect, and improve its behavior. And
the best part is that when you're ready
to ship, the same Monster app you run
locally can quickly be deployed as is.
If you use Monstercloud, you get a
hosted studio where your team can test
agents, inspect runs, and iterate
together. Agents are showing up
everywhere in modern apps, from cursor
and the editor to deep research and
perplexity for digging into a topic and
even support agents like Finn. So, if
you've been looking for a practical way
to get hands-on, this is a solid jumping
off point to get you feeling caught up
and start building agents you can ship.
In practice, an agent is a system where
a language model reasons about a goal.
It decides which tools or workflows to
use. It can pull in conversation memory
and keeps iterating until it can return
a final answer and the task is complete.
Mostra is how you build that in
Typescript. So, in this course, you,
yes, you will build a theme park
companion agent. It's the kind of
assistant you can imagine an official
park app shipping. It can confirm the
park you're talking about, pull live
weight times from the Q Times API,
factor in weather, recommend what to do
next, and even walk through a ticket
purchase workflow. As we build, we'll
work through the core building blocks.
We'll define an agent and its tools in
TypeScript. We'll use Monster Studio to
run everything locally and inspect
traces. We'll chain multi-step logic
with workflows and add memory and
storage so follow-ups behave
consistently. And by the end, you'll
have a monster agent you can deploy and
run inside any app. Look, 2026 kicks off
the decade of agents. So, if you ship
TypeScript apps, this is the course to
get ahead and even be the person your
team counts on to get agents into a
product. So, if you're ready to go,
let's start by getting MRA running
locally and looking at what it gives us
out of the box.